[Music]
France is known for its landmarks food
and art but what's less commonly
discussed is the corruption in its
corridors of power in his two
presidential terms Emmanuel macron's
cabinet has had its fair share of
scandals
facing accusations of abuse of power and
misuse of public funds three ministers
were changed in cabinet reshuffles at
least five ministers resigned after
facing investigations and accusations
ranging from tax evasion and employing
so-called ghost workers to fraud and
sexual harassment four current heads of
the Interior Justice defense and labor
Ministries have either faced or are
facing investigations this does not
include several secretaries advisors and
Commissioners facing allegations of
corruption and other wrongdoing
the minister for interior has been
accused of handing out favors in
exchange for sex
he says the sexual relations were
consensual
I have no comment to make sir I didn't
do it before I don't do it now and I
won't do it tomorrow I have confidence
in the judicial institution
the minister for justice denies
targeting judges who opposed him in the
past
I have used my rights to silence I have
always said that I get my legitimacy
from the president of the Republic the
Prime Minister and no one else
as well as those in power the French
far-right politician Marine Le Pen is
also Accused by the European Union's
fraud agency of misusing public funds
but none of this is new in French
politics former presidents Nicola
Sarkozy has been convicted Yak chirag
faced charges of corruption and abuse of
power and even the man who led France
against Nazi Germany Charles de Gaulle
was accused of using funds from the
former colonies to fund his campaign
in France a 15-member special Court
tries legal cases against politicians in
power activists say the system is
elitist and unfair because 12 of the 15
members are MPS and only three are
Judges French anti-corruption
Association anti-core has 150 cases
against politicians for alleged
corruption and says it's been fighting
to restore ethics for two decades
according to a recent poll more than
half of French people think that
politicians are corrupt
the Gap is getting wider between the
ruling class and French citizens who
cannot understand why politicians who
are accused of several charges do not
have to resign in the past politicians
stepped aside until the trials were over
that's no longer the case
former president Sarkozy is back in
court in 2023 he's expected to deny
wrongdoing and allegations of corruption
but it will take more than words for
much of the French public to start
believing their politicians are honest
Paris